[Music]
police in Arizona now on the hunt for
this man falah Hassan Al Maliki is
suspected of running over his own
daughter nearly killing her for becoming
too westernized apparently 20-year-old n
al-maliki reportedly backed out of an
arranged marriage last year and moved in
with a boyfriend and his mother in a
town nearby friends and family say n's
father threatened her for not keeping
traditional Iraqi values so was it an
attempted honor killing Robert Spencer
is the director of Jihadi watch.com
Robert are you surprised by this
scenario I'm not in the least surprised
this is not the first attempt at honor
killing and certainly not the first
honor killing at all in the United
States there have been others in Texas
in Georgia in New York and
elsewhere give us some of those examples
because you were rattling them off in
the commercial break to me and it and it
it it it stunned Brian and I to remember
just even in the last couple of years
here in America what has happened yeah
absolutely Gretch and you know the funny
thing is that uh like you said Iraqi
values but these Iraqi values are shared
by Egyptians syrians pakistanis
jordanians what nobody wants to talk
about is that this is a problem in the
Islamic community Islam uh does not
mandate any penalty for a father who
kills a child and Muslims are coming to
the United States and bringing these
values with them Amina and Sarah s were
murdered by their father in Texas for
having non-muslim boyfriend boyfriends
chadri Rasheed in Georgia murdered his
daughter for the same kind of situation
she was in a marriage and wanted a
divorce and he didn't like that same
kind of situation as nor Al Maliki now
uh and uh then there was musil Hassan in
New York who murdered his wife for
wanting a divorce uh he was oddly enough
the uh founder of a moderate Muslim TV
network nobody is standing up and
challenging the Muslim Community in
America to do something about ing
against the values and assumptions that
lead to this and as long as that
continues we're going to see more honor
killings in the United States and what
does that say about Rafi Barry who's
been chronicled here and she's saying I
want to go back to my parents I
converted to Christianity uh from is and
I will be killed by them does she have a
real fear you think RI kabari has a very
real fear you know uh my colleague
Pamela Geller of Atlas drugs.com has the
transcript up at her site that's Atlas
shrug. comom this morning of the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement interview
with RI gabari where she's very clear
about her father about her his devout
Islam about the threat that she's under
and the Florida Department of Law
Enforcement clearly has no clue about
any of it I urge people to go and read
that at Atlas shrug. comom the the fact
of the matter is that uh these people
are not being protected because people
don't understand the kind of threat
they're under and RI kabari is a classic
example of that she understands but
other people don't right because in the
western world it's hard to understand
how you would run down your own daughter
like this man is now accused of um and
he is obviously still on the loose and
that child May in fact die uh Robert
Spencer the fact that he's on the loose
also indicates that there's a support
network for these people and that is
something that has been insufficiently
Robert Spencer thanks so much director
jat.com straight ahead